les Marseillais ont renversé le cours de
l'Histoire la monarchie milanaise est
tombée la Révolution française du
football est en marche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça faisait plusieurs fois déjà que
beaucoup de club français flirtaient
avec
depuis Reims Saint-Étienne Monaco
nous-mêmes on a souvent flirté avec et
jamais elle a voulu nous sourire le
temps de redescendre sur terre la fête
va passer bien vite trop de bonnes
choses à déguster pour un seul soir les
Marseillais ont le triomphe tranquille
mais en cherchant bien pourtant il y en
a un pour qui le rêve continue Basile
Boli a eu un coup de foudre
[Musique]
vous en avez rêvé les Marseillais l'ont
fait le plongeon dans le Vieux Port
remonté sur la Berche et plus dur parce
qu'on est mouillé mais surtout parce
qu'on a bien arrosé dans les bars de la
ville avant et après le coup de sifflet
final tant attendu
en quelques minutes les rues de
Marseille sont engorgées la foule se
dirige vers la Canebière et le vieux
port pour une nuit de fête mémorable
les premiers supporters de France sont
tout à coups devenus les premiers du
continent combien sont-ils 50 000 100000
200000 t on est à Marseille alors on
dira un million
ce que l'on peut dire aussi c'est qu'à
aucun moment les forces de l'ordre n'ont
eu à intervenir pour contrôler cette
marée humaine
21h 16 joueurs débarquent sur une autre
planète 30 000 marseillais attendaient
depuis 5 heures dans le vélo de Drôme le
héros mais aussi la coupe 38 ans que le
sol français la désirait cette poupée la
voilà à Marseille Gironde à souhait elle
en a fait craquer plus d'un lallumeuse
[Musique]
les uns après les autres les joueurs
vont se saisir de la coupe et du micro
pour remercier leur public mais le plus
bel hommage a sans doute été rendu à
l'un des leurs Di Meco le Marseillais de
l'équipe de la division 2 à la Coupe
d'Europe il a tout connu dans le club de
ses débuts et à Marseille on aime la
fidélité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors Boli a renchéri comme s'il voulait
faire comprendre que lui aussi était
devenu marseillais à jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils l'ont tellement voulu qu'ils l'ont
eu elles portent maintenant toutes les
folies marseillaises
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]